rendez vous téléphonique cet après midi
entre le chef de l'état français
emmanuel macron et son homologue russe
vladimir poutine les discussions se
poursuivent sur la situation en ukraine
les etats unis menacent de ne pas mettre
en oeuvre le gazoduc north stream ii et
envisage des sanctions financières face
au risque d'une offensive russe côté
européen emmanuel macron et le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz ont pour
la désescalade et affichent leur unité
dans cette crise les etats unis qui ont
saisi le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
washington soupçonne toujours moscou de
préparer une attaque sur l'ukraine une
offensive prévue selon les états unis
pour la mi février est la ville de
kharkiv serait la première cible et la
population se prépare donc à faire face
le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov répond aux accusations
américaines de menaces d'invasion russon
l'écoutent
lieu cela pose aussi cela dépend de la
russie il n'y aura pas de guerre nous ne
voulons pas de guerre mais nous ne
permettrons pas non plus que nos
intérêts soient violés de manière
flagrante que nos intérêts soit ignorée